>> BRAY: Hello.
>> Hello.
>> BRAY: Welcome to the Android Track at the
GDD Brazil 2010. My name is Tim Bray. I'm
the developer advocate at Android group at
Google. Yesterday, I came to Brazil for the
first time. I've never been here before. I
found that it's actually quite difficult for
a Canadian to get a Brazil VISA. But on the
other hand, they gave to me a five-year VISA
so it should be easy for me to come back.
Today is more or less the introductory session
to the Android Track; what Android is, how
it looks to a programmer, why it's interesting,
and what directions we're taking it to. So
I'm going to spend a certain amount of time
talking to this slide. Let me see, is it big
enough? Can the people at the back see it?
Yes. Okay, good. So I'm going to spend sometime
talking about this because there's a lot of
material on it. So Android is not a specification.
It's not a standard. It's a great big chunk
of software. There's no separate definition.
This Android software is the definition of
Android. And so here's what's in that Android
software. Essentially, it's a reasonably current
Linux computer system underneath with the
Linux kernel but without a huge amount of
the other stuff that goes into Linux. A lot
of libraries, the utilities, and the subsystems,
and the user interfaces, and X Windows, and
all that stuff is just gone. It's a pretty
naked kernel. And then on top of that, the
next really big piece that we add is Dalvik.
Dalvik is the virtual machine that runs most
of the Android application code. It's a non-Java
VM. It's architecturally very, very different
from a Java VM. And it's optimized to run
programs on mobile devices. It runs its own
bytecodes, which we call DEX bytecodes, after
the program that generates them. The next
big piece is the Android application framework.
And if you're going to write an Android application
you really have to go through the Android
app framework. There's no other way to do
it. Now, the framework itself runs on the
native machine and the Android app framework
contains both a lot of code that runs on the
virtual machine and code that just runs natively.
And we'll talk about some of that in detail.
It's quite possible for Dalvik code and the
native code to call each other. That's done
using the JNI protocol that was developed
in the Java community. And you can go both
ways. Java code can call native code and you
can have native code that calls into a Java
application into the codes that runs on Dalvik.
Some apps have a lot of native code in them
as well. This is almost entirely games, most
commercial and straightforward apps that run
entirely on Dalvik. But you can't have apps
that have native code. I think that's all
the important--oh, of course, then also inside
Android is also the Harmony, the Harmony libraries.
This is the library that was produced by the
Apache project to be a replacement for the
Java SE libraries. Now, it's not the complete
set of Harmony libraries because Swing, and
AWT, and CORBA, and lots of other pieces that
are interesting in a phone are not there so
it's a substantial subset of the Harmony libraries.
So those are the big pieces that go into Android.
Now, probably the biggest single piece isn't
the Dalvik. It's the Harmony--it's the Android
application framework. So let's look at and
see what you find inside the application framework
when you look. So the green boxes are things
that run mostly on Dalvik written in Java,
and the brown ones are things that are substantially
written in C and run in native code, although
they may have a Dalvik API to them. So a lot
of them are just things that managed pieces
of the Android application framework. So there's
an activity manager, and a window manager,
and a view systems, and those are the things
that collectively take care of the screen
of an Android device, what's being displayed
on the screen of an Android device, and how
you interact with it and things like that.
There's content providers which is database
interface. There's a package manager that
takes care of, actually, running applications.
Hey, it's a telephone, there's a telephony
manager so that you can make phone calls and
do SMS and things like that. There's a resource
manager for taking care of all the binaries,
the audio, video, the--and that kind of stuff.
Location, every Android device has a GPS in
it and a location subsystem so there's a lot
of code in there to take care of that. There's
a thing for taking care of your notifications.
These are just some of the big pieces. One
of those things that has, "..." to say that
there are lots of other pieces in it. Over
on the native code side, there's a reasonably
large subset of OpenGL ES. They're mostly
for use by game designers, for people who
really want to do immersive, animated things.
SGL and Surface Manager are related to that.
There's a free type so there's a fairly complete
font handling subsystem in there. Every Android
device includes the SQLite database manager.
You know what, fairly early on in my relationship
with Android, I found myself, you know, setup
with a debugger typing SQL code into my phone.
And this was not exactly the future that I
had imagined that--there's a media framework,
once again, for doing little of the media
stuff. There's a complete--there's a big chunk
of lib C, Secure Sockets Layer. The point
I'm trying to make is that Android's big.
I mean, it's really a very, very large comprehensive
software suite. It wasn't built in a day.
They have been working on Android for years.
Many of the people who built Android had previously
worked at Danger and had previously worked
at B. So for a lot of them, it's sort of their
third go-around to building an operating system.
So it represents the culmination of a huge
amount of experience. So at the end of the
day as a developer, what we produce are applications.
So if you look inside an Android application,
which is an APK file, there's really three
things. The Android manifest is the part that
represents the bridge between an Android app
and the rest of the system. And it contains
all of these things the system needs to know
in order to run the app, like what permissions
it requires, what hardware it accesses, what
the various pieces of the application are.
Then you have the actual Dalvik classes, the
DEX bytecodes that actually make up the logic
of the application. And you have a bundle
of resources. These would be things like the
strings, and the audio files, the video files,
the images, whatever you want. So by and large
today, these things are produced in Java.
And as a result, they're actually written
with Java although they're, you know, they're--it's
not Java at run time, and as a result, we
get to inherent a large part of the Java tool
chain. And the tooling for doing this stuff
is excellent. There's a first-rate plug-in
for Eclipse. There are also somewhat lesser
evolved plug-ins for NetBeans and IntelliJ.
There are, you know, debuggers, and monitors,
and profilers, and all the different pieces
that you would typically expect in a modern
software development chain. It's not an official
Google project. But I'm happy to report that
for those people who don't like Java so much,
there is work in progress to make Python,
and Ruby, and Scala, all first class citizens,
so that you can program Android in a variety
of different languages. So this is the mainstream
of Android application development that probably
most of you would end up seeing and working
in. Now recently, we're seeing a lot of apps
that are what we call NDK apps as opposed
to SDK apps. NDK stands for Native Development
Toolkit and, basically, there are just the
same inside except they also contain some
binary libraries and JNI, the glue that you
need to connect back and forth between the
Dalvik stuff and the native stuff. These are
basically used by game programmers and only
by game programmers. Now from our point of
view in the Android group, we're not 100%
convinced that you really need to use C to
write a game. There are some actually quite
high-performance games on Android that run
100% on Dalvik. They were written in Java,
they work just fine. But a lot of game designers,
they don't even want to hear you talk about
that. As soon as you say Java, they go, "Oh,
oh, oh, I can't--I can't do that." These guys
want to live entirely in C and C++. Now if
you're going to do this, the tools aren't
as sophisticated. You don't get the nice IDE.
You don't get a lot of tools. You have to,
you know, have your own Ant-based build system
and so on. But, you know, game developers
are tough anyhow. They're used to pain so
they do okay with this. So suppose--so how
many of you are all ready Android developers?
How many people have--oh, excellent. So less
than half. So, good. So this talk will still
be valuable to you. So suppose you want to
become an Android developer. Here's what you
have to do. And let me start this by telling
you my own personal Android story. I've always
wanted to program phones and I--but I'm a
very strong believer in open source and in
nonproprietary approaches. And so when Android
was announced in 2008, I was very interested
in it. So I went and I bought one of the first
Android phones, the G1, and I got it in 2008
the day before Christmas vacation. So I was
going off to spend Christmas with my mother.
And so I got my new phone and I took a resolution
that I was going to write my first application
by New Year's Day, so in about two weeks.
And I made it. I succeeded in doing that by
about four hours. And it was astounding to
me how easy it is for somebody who is already
a Java or a C# programmer to learn Android.
This is one of the biggest, biggest advantages
to Android because it's very, very easy to
pick up. So how many people in the room are
already programmers in Java and C#? Okay.
You can all be Android developers by tomorrow.
I'm serious. It's--there's really nothing
to it. So what do you do? So the steps are
all here. Let me see. Are there any of them
not obvious? You just go to developer.android.com.
You get it. You--for most of--most people
would prefer to use the Eclipse plug-in although
some people prefer to use VI and Emacs. There's
lots of tools in there to help you debug and
profile and so on and so forth. One thing
that a lot of people don't do and they should,
Android is open source and you should use
it. "Use--use the source, Luke." You should
definitely go and get the Android source code
and download it. And here's why. Because the
documentation for Android is pretty good but
no software documentation is ever complete.
So sometimes you're looking at some API and
you can't figure out, "Well, how do I use
this location provider? This doesn't seem
clear to me." So don't guess. Just go into
the source code because the source code for
the operating system and the source code for
all the Google apps is there. Well, all except
one or two, most of the Google Apps is there.
And you can go and see how other people use
this. So don't guess, just copy. Absolutely
use the source. And then it cost $25 to register
as a developer. And then you finished your
application, then you go and you upload it
into the Android market and it's published,
you're finished. There's no review step. The
latency, the amount of time it takes to publish
an Android application is just a few seconds.
Now, that's nice but it's especially nice
when you've already published your application
and you find an embarrassing bug and you need
to fix the bug. So, "Oops." So you fix the
bug and you update it in the same day. No
waiting. That's a really, really big advantage.
So becoming an Android developer is very easy.
So what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
spend the next few minutes talking about the
pieces of the system that a developer sees.
So here's a list of the concepts that really
define Android. Now, if you go and look at,
you know, the suite of Android documentation,
there's lots more stuff than you see here.
But these are the parts that are really distinctive
about Android, that are making Android different
from other approaches to writing software.
And if you're going to ship something that's
worth having, you're going to need this stuff,
okay? So let's dive into this and introduce
the concepts that you're going to need to
know to be an Android developer. So an activity
is sort of the equivalent of a screen or a
Web page. It has some layouts where you show
things on the screen. This is where you display
text on the screen, where you display graphics,
where you animate things. It's where you receive
the events when somebody taps on the screen,
when somebody shakes the phone, when you had
moved location. It's where you play movies.
It's where you record audio. It's where you
play audio. All this stuff happens in activities.
And each application has a main activity that
this is the first one to be started. And when
you are finished with one screen, you move
to the next screen to the next activity, okay?
You move from activity to activity. So I have
a couple of screenshots here that show Android
activities. So here's, it's a music player
and here--boy--the projectors kind of overloading
the block. So the first screen is the list
of songs in the music player and the next
screen is shows, you know, the music playing
a song with, you know, you can vote it up,
you can vote it down, you can pause it and
so on and so forth. So these are two activity
screens you launch from one to the other.
Now, the life of an activity is a little bit
complex. And that's because--remember, you
are not in control. The user is in control.
The user can start your activity at any time.
The user can switch to a different program
at any time without telling you so you can
be suddenly stopped. The operating system
might destroy you because it's short of memory.
You know, Android apps, they're not like a
program running on a Web server where your
program will, in principle, run forever until
you stop or you have an error or something.
In Android, you have to be prepared to be
destroyed at any time because if the system
gets short of memory, your program is gone,
okay? So you have to be prepared to start
and stop. There's a lifecycle here you have
to learn and understand, and these are the
names of the programs that the callbacks they
get called. When your application is created,
you get the onCreate callback. When it gets
started for the first time, you get onStart
and onResume called together and then you're
running. You are the front. You are in control
of the screen. It's you and the user talking
to each other. Now, it's possible that a pop-up
comes up in front of you, you know, something
else in the system puts up a dialogue, then
that would come onPause because it means that,
you know, you're still--some of your materials
is still displayed but you're not in control
anymore. And then if they switch in another
application, that's onStop because, you know,
you're in background now. You're gone. And
then eventually, the phone is shut down or
the system shuts you down and that will be
onDestroy. So, you have to have code to handle
some or all of this. In the typical life of
an application, you know, you will be started,
you will be on the front for awhile. He will
put you away. They'll usually be talking to
somebody else. They'll bring you back then
it goes through onRestart and so on and so
forth. So what that means is that if your
application has any state you need to keep
track of, you know, you have to make sure
that you save that state during the onPause
or onStop and make sure that that you can
bring it back when you're brought up. And
it also means that people don't want to wait
so you have to be very fast about doing these
things. So activities are sort of the knit
of the Android user interface. Now, Android
is just a Linux system so you can do a fork
at any point, create a new process. You can
spin up threads any time and they will run
in the background. But remember, the system
can always just kill it. When the system gets
short of memory--and these devices, you know,
they really don't have very much memory. If
the system gets short of memory, it'll just
kill your process for you. But sometimes,
you need to run in the background and you're
doing some important or useful work for the
user and you really don't want to be killed.
So for example, suppose you are playing music,
okay? Or suppose you are tracking the user's
location to keep a diary of where the user's
been or something like that. So in that case,
you want to be in the background but you want
to say to the system, "Please, please, don't
kill me." And for this purpose you use a service.
So a service is really a lot like an activity
but the system will try very hard to keep
it alive. Now sometimes the system will kill
a service but then it will make a big effort
to bring it back again soon if it has to kill
it for awhile, it will bring it back. So here,
we have some examples of services. So the
first one shows the music player, the same
one we were looking at before. So then we
go to another application and the music player
runs as a service. And if you look at the
notice bar--you can't really see it in this
projector--up in the notice bar, there where
the red circle is, there's a little glyph
saying, "Oh, by the way, there's a service
running in the background," and that's one
of the rules. If you are a service in the
background doing useful work you should really
let the user know that you exist so you should
put a small notice in the notice bar. And
if the user, you know, pulls down a task manager
or the notification bar, you can see that
it will tell the user that, you know, the
service is running. Services are very interesting.
They're quite a bit less complex in their
lifecycle than an activity because they don't
have this issue of coming to background and
powered so much. There's really only--there's
only two methods--three methods that you really
have to worry about; onCreate, onStart, and
onDestroy. And most of the time you can assume
that you're running. Typically, if you look
at a typical Android device, there will always
be a few services running. The system has
some of its own and there will be others running,
okay? So the vast majority of your application
code will either go into an activity or a
service. This slide is a little bit of an
oversimplification. I discovered when writing
services that there's actually quite a lot
of other bookkeeping code you have to do to
set it up. It seems to me that it's a little
bit more complex than it needs to be. But
it's not too bad. Now, the next really important
thing about Android is intents. And intents
are one of the really new ideas in Android
and one of the things that make Android really
unique. So an intent is actually a fairly
complex object. So when you want to start
an activity or start a service, you always
give it an intent as the argument, okay? Say,
"Here's--go start an activity using this intent."
So the intent has quite a few things in it.
It has a target, which I'll talk about that
in a minute. It has an action that's well
sort of, there's a well-known--there's a set
of well-known actions in the system. Things
like display, and open, make a phone call,
and things like that. And then it also has
a Mime type. It's a same kind of Mime type
that goes with a Web page, so image/jpeg or
text/html or something like that. And you
can also have a category of optional extra
data. So suppose I want to start a service
to move from the music--listen to the music
player, so I use the target--the target for
that. So you give the service a target which
is basically a class, the class name, you
say go start a new activity with this class
name or start a new service with this class
name and that's saying, I want you to run
this various specific code for me, okay? Not
that's easy to understand. What's actually
much more interesting is you can leave the
target out and you can just say, "I want to
launch a service to play this music, to open
this webpage, to--oh, what was the other things?
To--I have some ideas in here, open webpage
or to make a phone call." Here's the phone
number, call that number. So you can make
an intent to do those things and just give
it to the system and say go start a service.
And, then the system will go and find the
best match with what you said, and this can
really produce some magic. So let me show
you some of the magic this can produce. So
here's a very common example of the kind of
thing that happens with an Android user. So
in the first screen, you see is a Twitter
client, so we were watching Twitter and this
is the tweet screen of Pat Chanezon, one of
the guys who's speaking maybe now, actually.
So when he came to the airport yesterday,
he lost his luggage and he did a tweet yesterday
about how I lost my luggage and he did it
with Foursquare. So there's a URL in the Twitter
thing, so I tapped the URL and the Twitter
client just sent an intent saying open the
webpage and that opened up the browser on
the Foursquare site saying, here's Pat's thing.
And on the browser window, there's a map so
you click the map and you go to a map of Sao
Paulo showing the airport, okay? And this
is done by Intent. And the system keeps a
stack of all the activities and this is the
reason that in Android, the back button works.
Okay. So every time the user presses the back
button, you just go back to the previous activity.
This is something that a lot of other operating
systems don't have and it's an immense huge
benefit to the usability of Android. Okay?
So that's one thing that you get for free
from Intents, here's another one. In the first
picture, this is the gallery app and it's
showing a picture I took of some clouds and
if I tap on the share button, a list of things
pop-up and that is a list of all the things
that our--prepared to ham--handle the data
type, image less JPEG. So you can query the
system to say which applications are in the
system that are able to handle image JPEG
and, then you can create a list. Now the way
this works is that an application can register
what's called an Intent Filter. And an Intent
Filter says, "I can do the following actions
on the following data types." And so there's
also an API, so an application can go and
see, you know, which app--which other applications
are ready. So here's a sharing menu, and what
that means is that anybody who is willing
to handle image/JPEG can be put on the sharing
menu for the gallery application. So on Android,
it's really, really, really easy to integrate
different applications. And there's an important
philosophical point here. Oh, I don't want
to talk about that yet, sorry. There's an
important philosophical point here which is
that Google does not believe that one website
should sort of provide all the services for
a user. And we don't believe that one application
should provide all the services on the phone.
So the Google website is famous for sending
you away quickly, right. We come here, you
find what you want, you go somewhere else.
And we--our vision for the phone is having
a bunch of applications that do a bunch of
different things and using Intents or able
to cooperate to provide the user with the
maximally full experience. Okay? So Intents,
you really, really, really have to learn about
Intents and understand them well if you want
to be an Android developer. Okay, the next
piece of apparatus that you need to understand
is a Broadcast Receiver. This is--this is
sort of like a service, it's--when you need
to be able to respond when something happens
but you don't need to be running. For example,
you need to know if they plug-in the headsets
or you need to know if the battery is low,
or you need to know that, you know, the screen
was dark but it was turned on. You don't need
to be running, you just need to be notified.
So you use this also an Intent receiver, this
is also done with Intents. So, you register
an Intent--an Intent broadcast receiver with
the system and when this event happens, the
system will deliver you an Intent to your
broadcast receiver and you can do whatever
is necessary. One special rule with broadcast
receivers is they have to complete quickly,
you're not allowed to take control of the
phone. If you spend more than five seconds,
the system will kill you, okay? So maybe the
right thing to do is to launch a service or
something like that. Okay. But here's an example,
this is actually a bad example, I realize
just today. This is an example of a music
player and he has a broadcast receiver for
plugging in the headphones, okay. So when
you plug-in the headphones, the music starts.
Bad idea. The other side is good, when they
unplug the headphones, the music should stop,
right? But that's the idea of how a broadcast
receiver works. Very simple lifecycle, you
start, you run, you exit, you almost certainly
won't be killed and that's all there is to
it. You get unreceive and way you go. Okay.
Another important part of the Android system
is content providers. So, as I said, the Android
framework includes the SQLite three database,
and if you go looking around the insides of
an Android device, you'll probably discover
that there are a lot of different databases
probably, you know, hundreds of different
databases. And typically, everything in the
system, every serious data that you want to
store on an Android is living--is most often
living in a SQLite database. Now, you can
use the database directly in your program.
There are some database helper classes, so
you can use it in your Java code or in your
C code. But more often, it's designed to be
wrapped around with the content provider.
And once you've wrapped data in a content
provider, then it's accessible to other applications.
So that is how, for example, if you want to
read the list of contacts out of the person's
address book or the list of songs out of the
music application or the list of phone calls
that the person has made or that kind of thing,
those are all done by content providers. It's
tremendously useful. Now, in theory, they
say that a content provider can be used to
wrap any kind of a data source. In practice,
it seems that it's always SQLite inside a
content provider if you look. My personal
opinion is that compared to the rest of Android,
these are a little bit difficult, and awkward,
and clumsy. They're not the nicest part of
Android. But they have pretty high performance
and they work pretty fine. Using content providers
is really quite easy. Writing a content provider
I found actually to be quite difficult and
tricky to get working. But they are tremendously
useful. So, you know, an obvious example,
of course, is the music. You know, the music
inside and--is stored inside the content provider.
And so you have a database, you have the content
provider and you can write a program easily
to find all the music on a phone and play
it. So almost certainly, you'll have to use
some content providers for any kind of a non-trivial
Android application. One good practice that
I'm going to mention now that is also going
to come up in the talk on--really, it's going
to come up in the talk on performance is I
think there's probably a little bit too much
use of SQLite. I think many people could just
be very happy just storing their data in the
file system and they use the database because
it's there so, you know, it doesn't mean you
have to use it. Okay, so threading is a very
central to Android apps. The threads on an
Android system are just ordinary Linux threads
and the API looks very--is the java.lang.thread
API. Now the reason that you have to know
about threads is that there's one special
thread in every application and that's the
thread that owns the user interface, okay?
And it's very, very important that you shouldn't
be doing network stuff or database stuff on
the user interface thread because it will
be instantly noticed by the user, that suddenly
the phone will become slow. So really, to
do any serious work in an Android Apps, you
have to put it on a different thread. So that
means you have to learn a little bit about
threads and how to use them. We have a couple
of nice helper routines to package up a thread
to help you avoid some of the details. But
I think most Android programmers do eventually
end up writing some threading code. I'm going
to actually show you some code here from an
application just to give you a feel for how
it looks. In this code here--I'll come over
to this side for a change. In this code, it's
reading some data out of a content provider
and it's writing it onto the disk using print
line and it's updating a progress bar, okay?
So the progress bar goes across the screen.
Now since the progress bar is part of the
user interface it has to be in the user interface
thread. But the code that reads the content
provider and does the printing cannot possibly
be one the user interface thread because it
might make the phone freeze, okay? So the
way it works is, first of all, we have a thing
called a handler we create. I'll show you
that in a minute. And then, so here's the
main method of the activity to onCreate. And
so we make a progress bar, okay? And then
I make a new thread based on the copy and
class to do the actual reading and copying.
So copyEnd is a runnable. And so the calls
variable there, that is a content provider.
So one of the methods in content provider
is move to next so use move to next of the
content provider. And so we go and we move
to next and then we pull the current data
out of calls with one of our own private routines
I haven't showed you. We print it and then
we say, "as call progress that set progress,"
do we actually call a method on the progress
bar to update itself. And that's a little
tricky because that actually sends a message
to the progress bar and then updates in the
other thread, in the user interface thread.
Now when I originally wrote this code, I had
a horrible race condition bug because of the
different threads and it took me a while to
find it. And then finally, there's this thing
called the handler and the handler is a way
of sending a message to another thread. And
in this case, I am going to use the handler
to put a title on the page saying how many
things I read and how many things I saved.
So I give the handler a runnable and send
that and it will run on the UI thread. So
you see a lot of this kind of code in Android.
And in my experience, most of the actual tricky
bugs and irritating problems that programmers
have come from threading because, you know,
threading has shared immutable state. It's
got the potential for race conditions, for
deadlocks, there's--you know, it's tricky.
So watch out for that stuff. Okay, another
piece of the system that I want to spend some
time on is the Android Manifest. So the Android
Manifest is an XML file that you have to create
and it is basically the declaration of the
app to the system. And it names any special
libraries, for example, the Google Maps library
that you might want to use. It declares all
the activities, the services, the intent to
filters are just there in the application
manifest. They're--they don't exist in your
Java code. They're just right there in the
XML. All that stuff is declared there. It's
terribly important to declare all the permissions
so when you install the application it asks
the person, you know, "This application needs
this permission, is that okay?" And if you
try and use, for example, the telephone without
having the telephone permission, your application
will blow up, okay? It also identifies the
hardware that you need. For example, suppose
you have an application that really needs
a camera. You say, "Okay, I use the camera."
Or it also declares which versions of the--of
Android this application can run on, and that's
very important because that's used by Android
Market. So the Market looks at the Manifest
and when the phone comes to look at applications
in the Market, the phone sends a message saying,
"Hi, I'm Milestone." You know, "I have these
pictures. I run this version. I have a camera.
I have no camera." And as a basis of this,
the phone will not see any applications that
he can't run. That's really important because
there's--there are a lot of different Android
devices and there are more different kinds
of Android devices coming all the time and
the Android Manifest is how we make sure that
nobody will ever see an app that they can't
run, okay? I could easily spend this whole
talk talking about Android Manifest but I
won't because that would be boring. There's
a bunch of other bits and pieces in the system.
I mean, the--you know, there's APIs for like
the camera, and the accelerometer, and the
GPS and all that stuff. Most of them are actually
pretty easy to use. And the good thing is
that you don't really have to learn how to
use them because Android's open source, and
because the world of Android Developer is
so big, you know, just type "GPS Android Example"
into Google and go on steal somebody else's
code. It's really the right way to do it.
And all of our code at this level is Apache-licensed.
So we explicitly are saying, "Please," you
know, "take this code. Use it." The way that
the screen is laid out, the screen layout,
is all done with some XML subsystem. There's
others. There's a way to provide versions
of your strings in all sorts of languages,
there's utilities for interprocess communication
and there's lots more of this stuff in here.
Okay, so I think those are really the big
pieces of Android that you will be exposed
to as a developer. Let me talk about where
we stand with Android. This is a picture--oh,
so dark--of a building on the Google Campus
called building--the number doesn't matter--it's
a building on the Google Campus and most of
the Android work is done inside this building.
And when I'm at the headquarters, my office
is right behind the green guy there. The releases
of Android are named after desserts and they
come out in alphabetical order. So here, you
can see the history of the releases of Android;
Cupcake, Donut, Éclair, Froyo. And I just
want to play you a movie here that came on
YouTube last week. Audio.
>> That's it.
>> It must have tranquilized because I heard
this duty is hard to catch up with.
>> Got it. Watch it, watch it.
>> BRAY: These are the Android engineers by
the way. They all came out to do it.
>> I'll just get a rope one.
>> There it is.
>> BRAY: So the next release of Android is
called Gingerbread and it's coming out pretty
soon because we put the statue up last week.
So you know, it has to come out pretty soon.
And I can't talk in detail about what's going
to be in Gingerbread but I will give you the
rough information on what we're working on.
So the thing that we care about probably more
than anything else is performance, performance,
performance. Every release of Android has
to be faster. And the reason we care about
performance so much is one word, "games."
People really like to play games on their
phones. And all the game developers are saying,
"Faster, faster, faster, faster." Of course,
as soon as we make it faster, they make the
game bigger and slower so, you know, you never
win. As a result--the other thing is that,
you know, here's the Samsung Galaxy Tab, and
there are many other Android devices coming
that are going to be bigger than this including
the Google TV. So we're making some improvements
to the software to make it, you know, easier
to work with a lot of different sizes. There's
a whole speech in the Android Track this afternoon
about different Android form factors. We're
putting some stuff in the framework to make
it easier for programmers. And this isn't
a Google thing, but there's some community
projects going underway to make Python, and
Ruby, and other languages available. But,
you know, that's only half of it. The other
area where we're really doing a lot of work
is the Android Market. And we want the Android
Market to be on the Web. Right now, you can
only see it from a phone. So we really want
the Android Market to be available in a browser.
We want it to be a lot bigger. We want more
apps and we want more countries. And we want
you. We want you to go and write more apps.
Please do it. And we want to make it easier
to handle the money. We want to make it easier
to search, easier to buy, easier to track.
Standby, I think there's going to be some
very interesting announcements in the immediate
future on the Android Market. So I'm done
now. I want to close with why I picked Android.
Occasionally, I am criticized because they
say, "Well, you're always," you know, "you're
always saying good things about Android because
you're such a Google fan boy." And that's
actually the reverse of the true--reverse
to the truth. I fell in love with Android
two years ago and I joined Google so I could
work on Android. So here's why I like Android
myself. First of all, I think that open source
software is better software. I believe that
100%. I don't think it's controversial anymore.
This is open source software and it's better
software. Secondly, the market is not--have
a policeman, you know? Well, we have a policeman;
we don't have a guard at the gate. So anybody
can put anything in the market. If it's illegal,
we'll take it down again but you can put anything
in. It's accessible. You don't have to learn
any new languages. Almost everybody already
knows either Java or C#, you can be a developer
in 15 minutes. The Android API is really nice.
It's not like the big enterprise APIs where
you have factory, factory, factory methods
and lots of abstractions. The intents, and
activities, and services are really well-designed.
They're slick. They're easy. They're beautiful.
They're nice to work with. And maybe most
important, nothing is hidden. Anything the
phone can do is accessible via the API. And
the reason for that is we trust the market.
If people do something with the phone that
is stupid and something in the application
that is stupid or dangerous, the word will
get around very quickly and people won't buy
it. The market is much smarter than Google.
Wherever you work, most of the smart people
are somewhere else. So the whole idea of Android
is to open it up, make it free, make it open
source, unleash the full power of the phone,
and trust the people to do smart stuff with
it. So thank you very much and I hope you
come to some more of the Android talks this
afternoon. Thank you for coming out.